hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute gibt ein seliges
türkisches rezept denn ich mache einen
türkischen mohnkuchen und das ist ein
rezept von einer lieben freundin erholt
dann macht sie nämlich immer ganz gerne
und ich habe ihn selber noch nie gemacht
machen heute jetzt zum ersten mal aber
ich kann euch sagen dass ich schon
richtig leckerer kuchen also so montag
der ist auch glutenfrei also können auch
menschen mit einer zöliakie oder mit
einer kriterium verträglichkeit gut
zubereiten weil einfach kein mehl in den
teig kommt und das ist dann so ein teig
den trinkt man dann mit whistler
zuckersirup und dann kommt noch eine
leckere quark sahne schicht oben drauf
und das ist halt ist schon wirklich
richtig lecker also solltet ihr auf
jeden fall mal ausprobieren
ich mache das jetzt heute in dem bug
rahmen mit 26 zentimetern ihr könnt auch
eine springform benutzen oder wenn ihr
das ganz groß machen wollt können das
auch gerne verdoppeln und einfach in
blech banken
dann ist nämlich auch ein richtig toller
blechkuchen und ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal die zutaten für den teig und
für den zero ich habe hier vier eier
ich nehme etwas vanille extrakt und
etwas salz dann ein becher zucker
einbrecher sonnenblumenöl ein becher
mode nine becker kries und dann die
zutaten für den sirup ein becher zucker
und ein welcher wasser und ein spritzer
zitronensaft also die sich aus nun ganz
einfach besser kuchen wo er einfach nix
in gramm abmessen müsst aber ich
schreibe euch trotzdem die zutaten im
gramm noch mal auf meinem blog
falls jetzt ganz genau haben wollt ich
mache jetzt aber nicht den teig sondern
macht zuerst in sirup denn der muss
gleich abkühlen
deswegen gebe ich jetzt wasser und zu
küssen als umgekehrt ist zu gehen
besonders gebe ich in einen topf und
verrührt es kurz und kocht es jetzt
einmal auf
und wenn frankfurt habe ich noch einen
spritzer zitronensaft mit rein und das
ist dann einfach so 2 1 bis 2 minuten
kurz kochen also das muss jetzt nicht
einkochen wichtiger werden die menge
eins zu eins also eine zeit teil sogar
ein teil wasser passt perfekt
es reicht jetzt im prinzip auch schon
das weite ungefähr eine minute
und jetzt nämlich dass auch direkt vorm
herunter denn der sirup muss jetzt
richtig gut abkühlen will ihn deswegen
um und stellen auch gleich kalt weil
wenn ich jetzt gleich den teig
zubereitet und der kuchen heißt aus dem
ofen kommt muss der sirup bis dahin
schon richtig kalt sein also sirup kalt
und kuchenheim den stelle ich kurz kalt
früher aber in der zeit jetzt schon mal
den teig an und dafür nehme ich jetzt
die vier eier gibt die in die schüssel
dann kommt da waren in der extrakt mit
dazu meine freundin im deshalb gar nicht
ich habe jetzt gedacht kommen diese wahl
extrakt muss mit rein
für mich passt ganz gut und bis jetzt
auch der letzte rest wenn der zucker mit
rein und eine prise salz und das lasse
ich jetzt einfach zu zwei minuten etwa
cremig rühren
und jetzt gebe ich dann noch den becher
öl mit rein
ich hatte frauen keine gläser deswegen
mache ich das so direkt meine gläser
fassen ungefähr so 52 milliliter also
das können wir euch so als mengenangabe
kann man nicht mehr unter uns
orientieren
das öl wird jetzt auch ganz frist
eingeführt so bei niedriger bis
mittlerer stufe
und dann gebe ich auch die rektoren und
chris mit dazu das ist außer das war
sehr gut vorbereiten könnt also total
einfacher teig total einfache creme und
dann einfach in den kühlschrank stellen
das ist einfach wird's unterrühren das
könnte dann auch hinkriegen
beim hocharbeiten
jetzt einfach den teig in die
vorbereitete form einführen ich habe den
ball kam mit backpapier eingeschlagen
damit auch kein tag ausläuft und es
empfehle ich euch hier auch dann später
kommt er direkt dieser zuckerguss drauf
also dieser zucker sirup und dann läuft
dann eben auch nichts aus
und so wird der kuchenteig geht es bei
170 grad ober unterhitze im vorgeheizten
backofen für etwa 40 minuten gebacken
alter brauch jetzt länger als ein
normaler teig und ich mache dann auf
jeden fall die stäbchen probe coulin
heiß aus dem ofen und dann geht es
gleich weiter
der kuchen gebacken und noch ganz heiß
die stäbchen probe habe ich schon
gemacht und jetzt stelle stehen so ein
paar mal ein damit ich gleich den
zuckersirup drüber geben kann und man
sieht auch das richtig schön locker
schön hoch gegangen
der schütze psycho schief aber das wird
gleich wieder flach das macht nichts
jetzt kann ich hier den kalten sirup
drauf geben also ganz wichtig gucken
heißt sie rückhalt ansonsten ziemlich
matschig und dann gehe ich das hier
drüber ich habe jetzt extra auch so ein
kleines blech darunter falls jetzt doch
was auslaufen sollte
das ist das auffängt dann einfach
überall hin bis zum rand
am rand war ich jetzt noch einmal
entlang mit so einer palette einfach
damit sich das löst aber ich glaube es
mache ich gleich in der sicherung zu
bisserl eingezogen ist auf jeden fall
gebe ich den jetzt in den kühlschrank
also ich lasse ihn erst kurz draußen
stehen und dann in den kühlschrank und
lassen dann komplett abkühlt und dann
können wir gleich die creme herstellen
und den kuchen fertig stellen der kuchen
ist jetzt schön abgekühlt und der sirup
ist auch gut eingezogen
und jetzt kann ich die creme vorbereiten
für die creme brauche ich auch nur drei
zutaten und zwar habe ich hier 250 gramm
magerquark 400 g schlagsahne und ich
benutze seine partner zum steifen und es
geht jetzt auch ganz schnell
ich schlage jetzt einfach die sahne
schönstein und gibt da gleichsam apart
mit rein
also direkt für telefon
das war so schön stapeln ich brauche
jetzt auch keinen zucker weil ich habe
schon den kuchen das nicht genug ist das
ding kommt in die creme gar keinen
zucker dann gebe ich noch zwei teelöffel
nicht mit 33 telefon islamabad zum kreis
in gröden auf kurzen
und wenn die sonne dann steif ist unter
die quarkmasse heben
das mache ich jetzt in mehreren
schritten erst mal eine kleine portion
fahne und dann den rest
und dann kommt die creme direkt auf den
kuchen drauf
und dann eben nur noch schön glatt
streichen
den kuchen denke ich jetzt noch mal ab
und geben noch mal in den kühlschrank
für ungefähr vier stunden dann ist
nämlich die creme richtig schön fest sei
es hier ob ich noch mal angezogen und
dann können wir eigentlich anschneiden
ich gedacht der kugel ist abgekühlt ich
habe den torten rahmen auch gelöst und
das ganze auf eine tortenplatte gesetzt
was ein bisschen schwierig war denn der
kuchen ist ziemlich klebrig und am
besten besetzte ihn direkt auf eine
kurven platte jetzt schneide ich ihnen
mal an
ja ich freue mich schon da ist nämlich
so lecker und einfach so saftig mein
körper so viel zucker siehoff drinnen
aber top ten
guckt mal ein ton wird es aussieht hat
sich hier unten dieser blauen getränk
schön mit dem zucker sirup obendrauf die
weiße schicht richtig lecker und wer
möchte kann das ganze jetzt noch ein
bisschen bestreuen mit ein paar
kokosraspeln passt nämlich auch ganz gut
dass so probierte ich probiere das stück
ist weil dann habe ich stück ist es
gleich in einem zelt und hängen ich weiß
auf jeden fall der kuchen schmeckt sehr
lecker ich habe das schon oft gegessen
so heute das erste mal selber gemacht
und ich hoffe dass ich dieses rezept
gefällt es ist ein sehr einfaches rezept
kann man gut vorbereiten den hätte ich
es auch stehen lassen können im
kühlschrank abgedeckt für den nächsten
tag als blechkuchen ich auch super
geeignet
also macht ihn auf jeden fall mal ein
leckeres türkis rezept und wenn ihr die
zutaten menge noch mal braucht die steht
auf meinem blog auf sell off - blog.de
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder biss dann tschüss und ihr könnt
gerne auch mal wünsche da lassen was für
türkische süßspeisen ihr gerne noch
sehen und bis dahin tschüss